various market forces have made our
packages a little wack lately
like have you been getting this
in a box like this
and why is this little thing
so have a lot of other people and
they're not too happy about it packaging
experts i talked to say retailers are
trying to avoid this size mismatch and
with the pandemic accelerating our shift
to e-commerce retailers are making
changes that are affecting the way we
receive and return our goods
in other words that unboxing experience
is changing
[Music]
when we were all stuck at home and
ordering everything online last year
americans went through more cardboard
boxes than ever before and as demand for
cardboard boxes rose to record levels so
did the cost of the stuff used to make
them shipping prices also soared so as
you can imagine retailers began
accelerating efforts to save on both
packaging and delivery costs to find out
what kinds of things they've been doing
i called matt reddington he helps
companies optimize their packaging so i
just want to get this on the record
unboxing is not going away right not at
all unboxing is taking off even more but
packaging itself is changing so the way
that we get our packages the way that we
go about unboxing is changing oh
absolutely the dynamic of how we obtain
our goods has highly been impacted by
covid and has really accelerated the
e-commerce push
to change packaging for the positive in
my opinion first he says you'll probably
notice more mailers they're cheaper
lighter and faster to pack than
cardboard boxes mailers are
about 75 percent less from a weight
perspective for the same size as a
corrugated box mailers also take up less
space in warehouses and on delivery
trucks and smaller sizes can be stuffed
right into mailboxes plus paper mailers
are super easy to recycle paper padded
mailers are in such high demand that
packaging companies like georgia pacific
are opening entire facilities just to
produce more of them adam gantz the head
of their mailer business told me that
while their main customer is amazon
they've been getting more and more
inquiries from small and mid-sized
retailers too
secondly when a box is necessary
companies are trying to keep things
minimal so hopefully you'll get fewer
boxes in boxes in boxes amazon calls
this concept frustration-free packaging
and while they introduced it years ago
the company is ramping up efforts to
expand the program by offering
incentives to third-party retailers who
are more efficient with their packaging
matt says the trend has taken off
amazon's really leading the weight here
but you've got target walmart everybody
else that's doing large e-commerce
falling away wayfarer things along those
lines so really what they mean from
frustration free packaging is the box
that comes from the manufacturer is the
box that gets mailed to you and there's
no extra layer of packaging that goes
over the top of that so it's frustration
free for the consumer but it's also
saving the shipper the retailer money
absolutely it's reducing cost in the
amount of packaging that's being used
these companies still have a lot of work
to do to optimize their boxes as many
people on social media point out
and while frustration free packaging
might save you time and it might help
save the environment
it's probably not going to save you
money analysts i talked to say that the
price of products won't drop just
because their boxes are cheaper to ship
and finally another big trend that
retailers are into
not shipping you goods at all you might
have noticed websites trying to push you
to pick your online order up in store
and to lure you in some companies are
even offering coupons and discounts over
the past year a lot of companies have
invested heavily in making their stores
function as fulfillment centers getting
more foot traffic is always beneficial
to retailers and as a macy's executive
said on a recent earnings call those
in-store pickups are free for you and
free for them
plus they're fast to fulfill that
promise to consumers of same day next
day they're allowing people to pick
things up there's also a huge savings
from them from a freight perspective a
similar trend is happening with returns
happy returns a service that partners
with retailers and allows you to drop
goods off without packaging at thousands
of locations across the country has seen
a boom in business their ceo david sobi
told me that return volume has been
roughly doubling every six months and
that the company expects to end the year
with about 400 merchant partners double
what they had last year so now that i've
spent the last week researching this
topic i'm left with this one thought
how are retailers going to make the
unboxing experience exciting and fun
when they take the box out of the
equation
if you've noticed other interesting ways
that your packages are changing leave me
a comment below and if you found this
video informative please hit that
subscribe button for more content like
this
happy shopping everyone
[Music]
you